junior girls section because we have
still Zoe tank there
we have a guest in studio with Christian
over to you speaking of the junior girls
uh Carissa first of all congratulations
for a final round Victory important one
you played against a good friend of
yours and it was a complete back and
forth game
how did you approach this one
um
I felt you know
at this point
um torments not so great but I really
want to finish on like a good note so I
took the game pretty seriously
um
I think I definitely messed up a bit in
the opening there and I got very
frustrated after I allowed like this
queen C7 move otherwise I felt that
I think you were talking about uh
these moments when you allow the queen
to C7 and whereas I felt that maybe I
should have just played F4 instead and
then these sorts of structures which is
like kind of like a French Carl that
kind of thing is kind of my jam yeah
yeah
um but okay so I allow this camera to
play with Queen G3 F4 and things kind of
got dicey on the queen side but I never
felt that there was like a very clear
knockout blow for her oh they certainly
did at this point she had this move
Bishop to E4 yes I did see that on the
engine you were planning to play a five
right I was going for F5 and I thought
like the complications and her time
trouble would be in the United States
crazy move B3 oh
if you take take on D2 and we didn't see
that
yeah touch the bullet on this one I did
I did got lucky
um
but yeah after Bishop F5 I thought I was
doing okay but things are obviously
still complicated yes yes you are you
are definitely doing okay here
and I think this nice finish with
rooftex G7 yeah a difficult tournament
for you as you mentioned you came into
this tournament as one of the big favor
is to win it how would you assess it
what do you see as uh things that you
need to improve after this one tell us a
bit about that
um I haven't really had an opportunity
to look over my games a lot in depth
just because such a fast-paced
tournament but I think generally
speaking probably
some stuff my openings
um gave my opponents some chances
and
maybe I'm just like a little bit Rusty
with calculation and stuff I was missing
some important moves and like my
critical games
um
so I'll definitely have to take a look
at those but I have another tournament
coming up actually talk to us about that
what's next for you I know you have a
very busy academic career as well you go
to Stanford that's very very difficult
to combine both that and just how do you
approach that what's next for you yeah
so I'm playing in the Women's World Cup
in Baku so I'm flying out in two days
and hopefully it'll be fun after I get
knocked out from that
I'll have a break from chess for a while
and then there's the Women's World team
in early September I'm gonna be playing
what about the U.S Championship that we
have
we have you don't know yet I'm not sure
yet we'll see got it we'll see how my
tournaments go got it yeah well Carissa
congratulations on the last round
Victory and good luck at the World Cup
thank you our congratulations as well a
nice way to finish the tournament yeah
congratulations on a nice and kind of
nice touch for the tournament uh you're
exiting kind of the junior girls section
right this was your last year playing
the championship but you've won it three
times you won the US Women's
championships so what like how do you
feel about your kind of Junior career
when you are now entering the the
women's one
um yeah I mean it's a little Bittersweet
as growing up usually is
um
but
not the best end to my Junior's career
but of course there's still going to be
a lot of tournaments to play and um
I'm excited for you know U.S women's and
all that coming up too
I hope it's not too bittersweet because
still you are a great American talent
very accomplished so you know one
tournament bathroom it happens but there
are a lot of them ahead thank you a lot
of bad tournaments ahead no
[Laughter]
[Music]
um just looking at the remaining games
Kelsey rose